で カタマンチャ・ビッカヴェ・ドゥッカ・ニロード・ガーミニ・パティパダ・アリエサッチャン
ドゥッカ・ニロード 苦しみをなくすということで
そのニロード・ガーミニ
そのなくすための なくす方へ
なくす道ということで
パティパダっていうのは
まあそれまた同じ道という一線ということで
アリエサッチャン 聖なる真理
だからドゥッカ 苦しみを滅する道で
道という真理は何なのか
アヤメーワ・アリーヨ・アッタンギコ・マッゴー
まあアヤンエーワ それはこのアリーヨ・アッタンギコ・マッゴー
聖なる アリーヨっていうのは聖なる
アッタンギコっていうのは八つで成り立っている
えーと マッゴー 道であると
だから聖なる あの方法
道なんですね それはまあ八つのカテゴリーで成り立っているんだということで
セイヤ・ティーダン それは何でしょうかと
サンマー・ディッヒ 正見
サンマー・サンカッポ
正思 サンマー・ワーチャ
正語 サンマー・カムマント
正業 えーと サンマー・アージーヴ
あの正命ということ サンマー・ワーヤームー
正精進 サンマー・サティ
正念 サンマー・サマーディ
正定ということですね
で それからその一つ一つの説明にいきます
カタマーチャ・ビッカヴェ・サンマー・ディッヒ
正見というのは何でしょうかと
ヨーコー・ビッカヴェ・ドゥッケー・ニャーナン
ドゥッ ヨーコー・ビッカヴェ・ドゥッケー・ニャーナン
ドゥッカ・サムッダヤー・ニャーナン
ドゥッカ・ニローデー・ニャーナン
ドゥッカ・ニロード・ガーミニーヤー・パティパダー・ニャーナン
アヤング・ウッチャティ・ビッカヴェ・サンマー・ディッヒ
あの正見というのはこの正しい見解でありまして
ですから あの普通に説明するとすごい長いものになるんですよ
で いろんな仏典ではこの正見というのはいろいろ方法で説明しているんですね
普通に一般的に言えば
どんなものに対しても正しい
正しい見解 意見を持たなくちゃならないんですね
で なかなか世の中でないんですけどね
誰しも人っていうのはこの
あの 本当のことを知りたい
本当のことを知りたいと言うだけであって
うーん まあ自分では知りたいと言うんだけど
結局本当のことっていうのはそんなに知りたいかないかっていうことは
あの まあ考えなくてはならないことなんですね
で よくあることっていうのは
自分では あの 自分の好みで物事を判断して
それは知っているということになるんですね
ですから 我々は知っているということは
これも知っている あれも知っていると言うんだけど
それは結局は自分の好みで判断して選んで
まあ知っているんだっていう風にしているものはほとんどなんですね
で まあ真理だから知っているということじゃないんです
ですから あの 結局知るということにこの判断入っているならばね
それは自分の好みになっちゃうんですね
ですから まあ正見あるんでしょうかというと
まあ大体は正見というのはないんですよ
で それからいろんなことを調べたり探したりする場合ありますね
真理は何でしょうかと
その調べたり探したりするときでも
あの自分の尺度というものは入りまして
それに合わせて調べたり探したりする
ですから いろいろ研究して何が発表して本なんか書いたりしたっても
そこにあるのは真理かというとそうでもなくて
これは自分の判断なんですね
ですから それで完全たる真理ということにならないんですね
ですから そこら辺はこれ大事なまあポイントで
この仏教で言っている正見というのはあるんでしょうかというと
あるわけじゃないんです
で わかりやすい例で言うならば
例えばマスコミュニケーションというこの世界は
まあ大変世の中で大変素晴らしい仕事をやと
まあ自分で威張ってるんですね
マスコミ世界っていうのは
我々の仕事はみんなに
あの まあ一応基本的にアメリカで決まってるこのマスコミに対するこの
あの道徳の項目で あの一般人々にあの真理を伝えなくてはならないということ
が一行なんですけど じゃあ真理そのものを人々に伝わっ
伝えていますかと マスコミっていうのは
伝えてないんですよ で
これはもうアメリカのニューヨークタイムズから始めて
イギリスのロンドンタイムズですか
BBC 放送局ですか  ABC
ABC 放送局 アメリカでイギリスの放送局 BBC で
で これ BBC ってのは一番 ABC 放送局よりもかなり幅広く活動していて古いんですけどね
じゃあ真理伝わっていますかと
伝わってないと思いますけどね
それぞれの人の好みで情報を選んで判断して
書き換えてストーリーを作って言ってるんです
だからジャーナリズムというのは
この取った情報をどのようにストーリーに組み立てるかという
この組み立て技なんですよ
真理はありのままに伝わる技ではないんです
だから時々このインタビューされた人もびっくりするほどのストーリーができちゃうんですよ
だからそれは一つのもうはっきり言えば芸術みたいなものであって
そのままニュースを伝えるかという情報を伝えるということはないんですね
ですから 結局このニュース番組にしたって
いかに面白く伝えるか
いかにたくさん人が聞いてくれるように
見てもらうようにするかという
このプレゼンテーションの技術ですか
発表というかね そのプレゼンテーションの技術をもう学んだりする
そういうのも大学でも入って
いろんな研究所でもこれだけ学んだりする
それで取った情報を まあこういうふうなものですよとストーリーに組み立てて伝わっちゃうんですね
ですから そちらも本当に事実伝わるかというと全くないんですよ
だから嘘の塊といえばね
今のマスコミっていうのは嘘の塊
嘘しか伝わらないというぐらいおかしいんですよ
で アメリカから流れてくるニュースは全部その通りですから
まるっきり違いますよ
そちらの利益を考えて
そちらの名誉を考えて
もういろいろからくり
時々ものすごい綺麗にニュース作ったりまでする
で 日本のマスコミが伝わっているものはどういうものか
ありのまま伝わるということはないんです
聞いてもらうか 見てもらうかという一般大衆の感情を計算して
一般大衆の好き嫌いを計算して言うだけなんですよ
この世の中にこういうふうな出来事が起きているんだということは
その通りで客観的に伝わるということはまるっきりないんです
全くないんです だからもうちょっとマスコミのこの技術
この大学なんかで教えてる
この発表 いわゆるプレゼンテーションでモードプレゼンテーション
メソドプレゼンテーション
いろいろ科目ありますよ
で そういうことをちょっと学んでみて
普通に流れてくるニュースを分解してみてください
あの おそらくどんな大学
どんな風にやってるかわかりませんだけど
マスコミュニケーションという学問は一応あります
自分の大学でもあります
で 初めからは自分の大学でマスコミュニケーションという学科がありましたけど
今はもう一つの大学でも
この去年からマスコミュニケーションという学科がもう始めて広げています
そういうところで 例えば何かニュースが出たとする
それで学生さんたちだから
そのニュースを分析してもらって
それはこの まあこのファクト
この事実 どのように組み立てて
どれぐらい面白く発表しているんですかと
で そういうことを勉強してみると
例えばこのニュースなんか分析すると
その事実をありのままに伝えるということではなくて
取った情報がどのようなストーリーになるかっていう
だから日本のニュースは
私はその目でちょっと分析してみるんだけど
何か出来事があったと聞いた途端
こちらで記者が一応ストーリーを作るんです
こういうストーリーでいくのだ
プロだから瞬時に頭の中ではできるんです
それはストーリーが ストーリーができたところで
この情報が必要なんですよ
ストーリーに入れるために
だから自分のストーリーにこの情報を入れる隙間があるんですよ
で それで調べに行くんです
だから調べに行く前にどんなものを調べるかということは決まってるんですね
だから何か起きたかということじゃないんですよ
起きた情報を取って言ったら
このストーリーのこの型にはめないんですよ
自分で四角いものを調べるか
三角のものを調べるか
最初から決まっていくんですね
だから現場に行ったら
もう見たらもう三角のものはほとんどないんだったら
まあ四角いものばっかりだったら
それを一つも選ばないで
四角とは言えないんだけど
なんとなく四角っぽいものを取って
それを三角にして流しちゃうんですね
で どんなニュースでもいいんですよ
これは授業じゃないんだからね
難しいんだけど で それでいろいろ人はインタビューするでしょ
答えがインタビューする人が持ってるんです
持っていて それ聞くんです
そこで向こうは言わないんだから
ああそうですね そうですねという答えになるように質問を作って出すんです
プロになればなるほど
そういう風なインタビューなんですね
例えば人が人を殺したりする
そこで取った情報によって
この人はもう あの ものすごくこの独立
独立じゃなくて この引っ込み生活で人間とはなかなか付き合いしなかった人やと
かすかにそういうことができたとする
で それで突然発作的に人を殺したと
で じゃあなるほど これでもってこういうストーリーを作りましょうということって
まずストーリーを作る
そこで あの必要なのは引っ込み症でしたよというぐらいのことをね
そこで全然関係ない人にいろんなこと
あんたその人を見たことがありますかね
あまりないんですよ 当たり前でしょうに
そこら辺の人ってみんな見たことがあるわけじゃないんだから
やっぱりあまり挨拶もしないんですね
そうですね やっぱりそこら辺とあまり近所付き合いはあまりなかったんですかね
あまり知りませんね 誰も
それでも涙流しながらそれを放送する
やっぱり誰とも付き合うことをしなかった人
誰とも挨拶した人しなかった人ですよ
自分の頭で作ったストーリーなんですよ
事実じゃないんです だからそういうところは別にあの人をそう言ったわけじゃないんですよ
これじゃこっち事務所も何年もやってますけど
じゃあ２階にいる人をインタビューしちゃっても
誰の顔も知りませんだから
もしこちら事件起きちゃったら
そのレポーターが これは変な人間付き合いは嫌うまるっきりもう隠れている組織だよと言いたければ
いとも簡単にできます
玄関の右側にあるあっちの店舗に並んで
この 2階のあの人々はどうですか？どういう人々ですか？見たことがないな
もうすぐ でも 3年以上いるんだけど
一度も見たことがない
それでしょ あるいは大家さんに聞いたって同じことだから
もうこの今年にもこの部屋を借りたんだよぐらいの言うんであって
だから何年でやはりそれはわかりませんと
どういう人々も全然わかりませんと
じゃああんた行ったことがありますかと
前は一回 二回 この事務所みたいな事務関係でありますけど
それで何やってるか全然わかりませんと
それもう抜群の情報なんです
ストーリーを作るために
ですから それで真理というものは伝わるかというと伝わりません
そのいろんな事件が起きちゃったら
ものすごい話すでしょうね
でも立ち入り禁止なんですよ
特に日本ではものすごい厳しいんですよ
だから鈍いんだから 警察はものすごく
これすごく時間かかる
ですから ちょっとしたことを調べようと思ったら
その部屋に建物ある一切の資料をトラックごとに持っていく
持っていって保管している
それだけのことなんですよ
全然この調べるとかはないんです
だからどこかに何か事故ったら
それを丸ごと立ち入り禁止にして
1ヶ月間  1年とか平気で
そこでどんなレポーターが行ったっても何にもないんです
情報が 日本の警察も何も言わない
日本政府も何も言わない
もう完全全て秘密主義っていう
日本の場合はね 他の国の場合は全部電話かけたら言いますけどね
それ国によって違いますから
日本の国のやり方っていうのは
もう何から何まで絶対言わないという
ある憲法は守らないということで
国民には権利はないんだ
知る権利もないというふうなやり方でやってますけど
誰も裁判を起こしませんだからね
たとえ自分の人が病院で殺したっても
カルテは見る権利ないでしょ
平気で殺すでしょうに
見る権利はないんです
ですから 一旦病院に行ったら
そちらのやりたい放題で
あなたには何の権利もないんだと
もし勝手に病気治ったらお金払って帰れと
で 病院のやり方 人が死んじゃったら病院の費用を払って遺体を持って行けと
この間 この解剖もしないで解剖したんだと
ちゃんともう全部書いたりして
いくつかケースも出ましたからね
そういうことだから真実知るはずがないんですよ
それぐらい秘密主義で
どこへ行ったってね だからそれぐらい秘密主義で
もうニュースも取れない
もし何か情報を取ったならば
それは盗んだことになるんですよ
何か資料でも記者が取ったら盗んだことになるんです
ですから これは証拠ですよとマスコミで流すことはできない
私は一度も日本で見たことがないんだから
そうやってこういう人はこういうことをしました
これは証拠ですよと出したことは
他の国々の新聞ではよく見たことがあります
この人書いた手紙 こういう手紙ですよ
それでみんないろいろ怒るんです
あんたどうやってその手紙手に入ったんですか？というね
それはジャーナリストの自由であって
聞く権利はないんだと
ジャーナリストは情報源は言わないんだと言って威張っちゃうんですね
まあ威張ったっても それはそうでないとなかなかね
調べることはできないんだから
そういうふうに証拠を出して喋ったことがありますか？新聞でも私はあまり日本の新聞を読みませんだけど
いろんなことを言うんだけど
一つもいろんな証拠 資料のコピー見せたりとか
そういうことだから このやっぱりこの
で 日本のケースはすごいいいケースなんで
勉強するために この事実と伝わるものっていうのはどれほど隔たりがあるかということにも
でもだからといって いろんなからくりをしてずるいことをして情報を盗む
BBC 系にしたっても
本当の事実は伝わって伝わらないんですよ
完全に嘘をインチキ作って流す場合
ものすごいたくさんある
で その場合はイギリス政府とイギリス人の好みでやってるんです
で イギリス人が嫌いと潰したいという人々の国々に対して
その情報しか選ばないと
例えば ある国のあの民族差別であろうか
一人ぐらい殺されちゃったら
もう不正的にいけない方向で殺ったならば
ものすごいワイワイ騒ぎだすし
ある国で人万人人殺したってのは平気で
まあその国のことだから我々は立ちさばりしませんということで手を抜く
このピノチェの話ってそういうことで人万以上人を殺しちゃったんですよ
独裁者で でもピノチェ個人がイギリスのもうおもちゃみたいな人の人の人なんですね
何もしない 反対もなし
自由にしてあげちゃったんです
いろんな国際的な法でその人を返してくれと
この人は裁判にせなくちゃいけないんだと
どうせできません 病気ですからと
その時はある個人の体調が悪いということで
他の場合は体調悪ければ悪かろうか
もうそれを時間前に死ぬんだと言ったっても
あんた罪を犯したんだから審判しなくちゃいけないということに
すごい凶暴なんですよ
そういうことだから 世の中でこの真理知りたいというのは口先だけで真理知りたい人もいないし
真理伝わろうとする人もいません
我々も真理知りたくはないんですよ
自分の好みでねじ曲がって知る
例えば日本人だったら北朝鮮に対してもう批判的な情報しか読もうとも聞こうとも見ようとも考えようともしないんです
もし北朝鮮にいいところ
いいポイントあったら
それは全部無視 ゴミ箱に
で そういう風な世界なんですよ
日本人だけ悪いわけじゃなくて
中国人にしても みんな人間っていうのはそういうやり方なんですよ
だから世の中で人間っていうのは真理知りたいっていうことはないんです
あるままのことを知りたいっていうことはない
で 伝える これで食べてる人々
マスコミという 全然真理伝わってあげようと
私たちはこれで食べてるんではないかと
だから真面目に仕事をしなきゃよくない
そんな考え方ないんですと
ただみんなワイワイと
もう感情で湧き上がってくるようなストーリーを作って
それで食べていけるではないかと
ですから 私はこのいろいろ本なんかいろいろいくらあったっても
全然真理じゃないんだと
その人の感情でだけなんですよ
そこは科学的な研究までも染みついてるんですね
逃げてないんです 一切
もう科学的な研究したっても
その人々の人間環境と利益のこととかね
だからいろんな研究は抑えておく
利益にならないと 今まで儲かっているものがなくなるんだと言ったら
その研究を抑えておく
そこで間違っているデータであろうとも
それは調べようとしないで
結構金になるんだなと思ったら
瞬時に発表して それで商売にするということは
もう科学の世界にもはっきり出したものなんですよ
アメリカのこの月面着陸のドラマ知ってますかね
裏のドラマが で ガキたちの戦争喧嘩みたいな裏ドラマがあるんですよ
で ソ連にはすごい本当はその当時で科学者がいて
その連中には他の遊び何もないし
で 研究まあ共産主義だからね
そこでもう朝から晩まで徹底的に研究して研究して
誰も知らないうちにサササササッともう衛星なんか宇宙へ飛んじゃって
で 研究始めたんですね
それでこの まあすごい長時間の何10年
何20年  40年という計画で
一応技術開発を始めたんです
そこ情報を取ってみれば
これ大変やと それだったらソ連の方が科学的な世界で勝つんだと
いて ただ単にアメリカのこの何て言いますか
顔に泥塗られたことになるんだから 1
年以内で何とかしなくちゃいけないんだとかね
それでもうただただそれための何とか何とか工夫していろいろなんとかもう打ち上げちゃう
で うまくいかないと それでとにかくソ連は月面着陸する計画はなかった
計画ではなくて それはこの長い間の研究の場合はそんな大したことはないんですよ
一番大事に必要なのは宇宙ステーションだよと
だから宇宙ステーション作ってから
どこにも簡単に行ったり来たりすることはできる
例えば宇宙ステーションできちゃったら
まあ週2回ぐらいでも月に行って帰ったり
行って帰ったりすることはできるんです
どうせ無重力の世界だから
だからそこは変でなくて
こちらは一応それより先に一般人っていうのは科学も何も知りませんだから
ほら 皆さん ソ連はまだ地球を回っているだけで
もうアメリカが月に降りてきたんだ
だから膨大に それだけものすごい苦労したんですよ
そのために だからその計画も今はもう完全に使って
計画もあの科学技術も使ってないんです
あれはそれで終わりなんです
アポロ計画となんとかっていうのは
それ以上何もできません
それでも最近なんですね
この行って帰ってくるような機械飛行機作ったのは
だからでも自分たちがすっごい優れていて偉いと
で それするためにやっぱりソ連を潰さなくちゃいけない
ソ連の科学能力を潰さなくちゃいけない
それ綺麗に潰しちゃったんです
科学者みんな 今ソ連には何もできません
誰もいない そういう研究できる人も誰も
[背景音楽]だから別に私はそれを褒めているわけじゃなくて
この科学の世界にしたっても
単なるもう事実の研究
技術の勝負とかということじゃなくて
ただただ自分たちの感情と自分たちを名前売るための
まあすごい俗的な気持ちでやってるものなんで
そちらに事実っていうものがあるわけじゃないんです
どちらにでも人間の ソウルにしたっても
アメリカにしたっても
もうどこでもニュースも何も事実伝わるってことはないんです
だからこの人間の心の問題なんですよ
人間っていうのはどこかで真理知りたいという気持ちあるんだけど
それが本当かと 結局知りたいっていうのは
自分の感情に合うことだけなんですよ
だから真理を伝えるんだと
真理を知りたいんだって
そんなものは単なるこのうわごとなんですよ
だから証拠っていうのは大変な言葉なんです
普通の人間できるものじゃないんです
私たちももう平気でいろんな真理を隠すでしょうに
それは言わない方がいいよとかね
だから世の中のもう本当に全て嘘で固まっている
嘘の上で嘘 嘘の上で嘘で固まってる
この世界というかね だからいろんな問題が起きたりする
どんな人間関係だったら
それは嘘の世界なんですよ
どんな小さな人間関係にしたっても
例えば親と子の人間関係にしたっても
親が自分知りたい情報しか子供に対して取ってないんですよ
子供の本当の これ こいつは何者かと
それは知りたくないんです
自分で判断した 自分で頭で作ったイメージにはめる
はめられる情報しか取ってないんですよ
だからトラブルが起きたりするでしょうね
びっくりする時って 母親が
いえ そんなことはするはずがないんだと
あんな平気であんな言葉言えるんだからね
私の息子はそんなことするはずがないんだと
そんなことを言える言葉自体も
この事実は知りたくないっていうことなんですね
ですから この母親は子供のことを知らない
子供も母親のことを知らない世界なんですよ
夫婦の間でも互いに知ってないんですよ
自分の都合に合う情報だけ相手から取ってるんですよ
じゃあ互いに知り合おうと思ったって無理なんですね
もし旦那が じゃあ奥さんのことをじゃあやっぱり知らなきゃ困ると
じゃああなたのことを言ってくださいって言ったら
奥さんが何を言うかというと
自分の世界で知ってほしい部分しか言わないんです
全部言うことはないんです
だから誰かが来て やっぱり夫婦互いに理解し合った方がよろしいと
ですから よく話し合って
いろんな問題に 子育てであろうか
料理の献立のことであろうか
買い物のことであろうか
それ奥さんの世界だからね
そういうものについても
男の人もちゃんと知っておかなくちゃいけないんだとかね
はい わかりましたと そうやって決めて
じゃあ情報交換しようと思ったっても成り立たないんです
その時も買い物について旦那が知ってほしいものしか奥さんが言わないんだから
まあわかりやすく言えば
私は大変だ 大変だ えらいことやってるんだってそれだけ言いたがってるんですよ
じゃあ男の世界知ってほしいと思ったら
男も同じこと 私は大変だ
すごいことやってるんだと
並のことじゃないやと
そういうふうな その自分の威張るところだけ
言いたくなっちゃうんですね
そういうふうなことだから
人間の世界ではこの証拠っていうのは成り立たないんです
だからこれ大変なことなんですよ
この八正道の一番目の正見というのは
やはり一切の固定概念
自分の感情を置いておいて
ありのままという これは自分で知りたくない
そんな上から見る世界じゃないんです
私はそれ知りたくないという
そんなはずではなかったとかね
そういう世界ではないんです
ありのまま知るということは正見なんですね
だからこの軽々くいろんな仏教テキストなんかではね
正見の説明とかね あるんだけど
じゃあ誰一人もそこら辺まで正見のことを考えてとか
誰も考えてないと思いますけどね
みんな真理知ってるんだと思ってるんだから
いわば勘違いなんです
じゃあ私は言ってること嘘やと思うとなればね
この仏教の研究者が書いている三十センチ
二十センチ 二十五センチ
四十センチの厚さはね
いろいろ本があるでしょ
読んでみてください 正見の説明では
まあそれ何か書いてますかと
自分たちの眼鏡で色眼鏡で見て書いてるだけではないかということを発見できるかなと思いますけどね
だから正見というのは
あの なんでしょうかね
仏典ではね まあいろんな釈尊で説明していて
例えば世の中のことというのは
そんなに気にしなくても
例えばまあ汚れた水を飲んだらね
体がお腹が壊れますよとかね
まあそれも正見なんですけど
まあそれぐらいのことは大体世の中で知ってますから
知らなかったら調べればいいし
それは仏教を言う必要はないでしょうに
汚れた水を飲んだらお腹が壊れますよとかね
体に合わない 合わないものを食べたら体の調子が悪くなりますよとかね
そんなことを言う必要はないんだからね
勝手にやればいいんだからね
それぐらいのことはね
ですから まあ風邪引いたらどんな薬飲めばいいかとかね
それはまあそこら辺で勝手に研究してやればいいんです
ですから その真理の世界は仏教で扱ってないんです
だからって仏教手なずせている人々いるんだからね
それは正見 なんかちょっとあまりも単純すぎやとかね
仏教の正見について言いたがる人々はいますけどね
それはそういうふうに言いたがっている人々の頭の悪すぎだけなんですね
仏教はまあまあそういうことには興味も関係もないし
もう勝手にそこら辺は勝手にやればいいし
で それからこのカマサカササマーディティという
この人間に普通には理解できない
仏教で教えてあげなくちゃいけない正見一つを書いてるんですよ
これもこのテキストでないんだけど
で カマサカササマーディティというのは業なんですね
業っていうのは自分のものは業であるということは理解してほしいと
それを大変な特別な教えで
で 我々の生き方 人生の計画というかね
どんなこの設計図で どんな青写真で私たちは生きていますかと
で 生まれた時からもう大きくなって年取って死ぬという
まあ一応青写真があるでしょうに
それ変えることはできないんですよ
いくら頑張ってももうちょっと背が高くなってほしいとかね
何かに引っかかって頭と足を引っ張ってもらったってもね
まあもう死ぬか それぐらい苦しむになるだけであって伸びません
そういうのは決まってるんです
で 皮膚の色は変えてほしいとか何とか思ったってもね
なかなか無理なんですよ
で まあできるところでみんな頑張ってますけど
でも本当はやらない方が体にとってはいいんですね
で あまりやっちゃうと細胞がおかしくなっちゃって
ガンになって早く死んでしまっちゃうという結果になってしまっちゃいますね
で それから科学系は自分に能力あるか
美学系 芸術系 自分に能力あるかとか
それを勝手に決めることはできないんですよ
もう青写真にも一応あるんだからね
で 変化できるところは変化しますけど
基本的には変化できないところはあります
これは建築家の仕事に例えてみると
建築家に建物を作ってくださいと頼んだら言うんですよ
もうお客さんに聞くんですよ
クライアントに あなたはどういうもの
建物が欲しいんですか？とか
部屋はどれぐらいあればいいんですか
どんな大きさでいいんですか
外の建物は見た目はどのようにすればいいんです
屋根は 聞くことは聞くんだけど
建築では基準というものがあるんですよ
それは絶対変化することはできないんです
それはもうしょうがないんですよ
だから一応基本的な決まりが
骨組みがあって その中でほんのちょっとほんのちょっとの変化はできますけどね
例えば あの逆立ちしたピラミッド型の建物欲しいんだと
思ったらどうしますか
私は家作りたいんだけど
それは逆立ちっていうんですか
このまま逆さまにしたピラミッド型でなければいけませんと
そうするとできますか？できない
現代技術でできないわけないんだけど
その中でやっぱり基準というものが成り立っちゃいますよ
まず逆立ちした三角形というのは
まず作りにくい 厳密にバランスを整えないと作りにくい
それでもほんのちょっとのこと
バランス崩れる可能性あります
倒れますね ということは土台問題になるでしょうね
結局三角形 逆にした三角形は下に埋めてもらわないと
まあ逆立ちした建物作りましょう
こうやって もうこうやってコンクリート作って
ここまで埋めてもらうんですよ
その上建物は作られます
結局四角になっちゃいますよ
そうするとエネルギーの流れは
ですから このもうどうにもならない
誰にもできない この基本技術
基本的な決まりがあって
それを守った上で ほんのちょっとほんのちょっと変化はできます
だから我々の人生の青写真にしても
基本的なことがありまして
そこは守りながら何とか何とか調整できるぐらいのことなんですね
そこは誰もわかってないんだから
いい加減なことを世の中で言ってますよ
人間について語るものは
仏教から見ればまあほとんどいい加減なんですよ
例えば西洋では まあ環境でしょうと
何でも環境によって天才も生まれますよと
人は科学者になるか すごい素晴らしい音楽家になるかということは
小さい時はもうできますよとかね
小さい時の環境によりますよと
そういうのは全ていい加減なんです
我々の希望通りに人間を作ることはできないんですよ
だから一部を見て それが全てだと説明して
そんなにも自分の希望通りに物事を行くということはありえないんです
[背景音楽]ですから
そのなかなかあり得ない先がわからないということは
もうそれは神様やという人々もいて
それもいい加減で ただ言ってるだけで会ったことはないし
証拠はないし 神を体験した人っていうのは一人もいません
それはテキストにだけいるんですね
それ不思議なことで モーセやらね
そういう精神病気な人はもう会ったことはあるんだけど
肝心のジーザスさえも会ってないんですね
神に なんか山の中に隠れた時は
まあなんかモーセやら何人か来て話してたんだと
神は来てないんですね
その時に ですから このまあ一応自分でそういう説明もできるんだという説明なんですね
こういうことはあります
これはどういうことかと
説明してくださいと では説明します
この説明ってのは科学の世界でよく使うんですよ
いろんなデータを取って
そのデータを説明するんですね
だからキリスト教でも
この神という概念で人間の運命というかね
それを説明しているんですよ
説明は事実ではありません
これはあくまでも説明なんです
説明だから その人のいい加減な気持ちなんです
あの進化論も説明なんですよ
いろんなサンプルを取って取って取って並べて
それからストーリーを作るんですね
だから進化論という本が成り立つのです
進化論にはもうローマ教会は反対なんですけど
でも自分たちのストーリーは自分たちの説明は正しいと
どちらもどうったことないんですけどね
だから仏教の立場から見れば
進化論も一つの説明で
全部神が一括りで作りましたっていうことも
それはそれなりの その人々の勝手な説明で
誰もそれを経験したわけじゃないんですよ
誰も進化経験したわけじゃないんです
だからそういうものに絡み合って
いろんなそうではない
ここだと思います いえ
違いますよ そうやってみんな永久的に知識の中で
この概念の中で絡み合って苦労しているだけで
真理って何なのかということを知る方法はもう見つかりっこもないし
もう見ようともしない
見たくもない 真理は そういうことで
仏教でいう正見というのは
この単純明快なものではなく
とても大変なものなんです
それはもう心の問題であって
心の根底から真理を知りたいという気持ちでなく
たとえ自分の希望気持ちは何であろうとも
それで真理は妨げてるんだと
真理を妨害しているんだと
と理解しなくてはいけないんですね
知りたいという自分の気持ちさえも
知ることに-- 知ることを妨害しているんです
そういう大変なことだからなんですよ
正見生まれたことは悟りやというのは
正見が生じたということは
もう悟りましたっていうことです
それでまた話脱線しましたが
戻りますけど この そうやって人間のこの阿呆写真
それは仏教では業と読むんですね
カルマと読むんですね
だから業は自分が行った出来事なんですね
行為が結果作るんだと
だから全て行為の流れなんですね
で 実体は でなく物事を考えているんですね
全て行為 function function function
という機能 機能 機能であって
で 機能があって物体っていうのはない
それはなかなか簡単にわからないかもしれません
ただ 包丁という物体があって
切るという機能があると我々思ってるんだけど
それはもう厳密に機能がなければものがないんだから
あの 物そのもの自体も機能なんですね
行為なんですよ ですから
行為は二種類に分けて
物質の行為と まあ生命の行為ということがあって
物質の行為はもうすごいわかりやすいんですよ
これはこの不安定なエネルギーを安定にしようではないかなという働きで
この安定感を探していって
物事は動いてるんです
なんで鉄が錆びるんですかというと
やっぱり酸素というのは不安定なもので
もう誰かに引っかかってもらわないと
自分一人では不安定なんですね
そこで錆についちゃったら
錆から一つ奪っちゃうでしょ
エレクトロン一つ 奪うのはいいんだけど
奪って逃げることはできないんですね
鉄はあげませんだから
それ私のものだからっていうこと
あげちゃったら私が鉄でなくなりますよと
ということになります
そこで着いた酸素はそこで止まっちゃうんですね
で それを錆びるというんですね
一旦自分が不安定だから
もう何かについちゃったんだけど
それで不安定に安定するためにものもらい-- もらったんだけど
そちらも鉄の元素も残念ながら離してあげないんですよ
それでフェロスオキサイドという
あの 錆が生まれてくるんですね
オキシダイゼーションという
まあ化学で言いますけどね
あの さん-酸素化ですかね
まあそうやってこの自然の行為の流れっていうのはもうわかりやすい
なぜ元素 元素自体行為そのものなんですよ
原子核って行為そのものなんで
だから原子核を割っちゃえばすごいエネルギーが出るでしょうに
想像を絶するエネルギーが出てくる
どれぐらいエネルギーあったか
もうびっくりするぐらい
だから簡単に割れるのはウランとかね
そういうバカでかい原子核だから簡単に割れるんですよ
あまりにも大きすぎて
で 他のものを割ることは今の技術ではできません
だからウラン爆発させて
あの 反応を起こしちゃって
まあ原子の力とかなんとか言って使ったりしますけどね
ものすごいエネルギー持ってますよ
ウランももう普通の土と同じ
別に何も変化しないと何もことないんですよ
でも簡単に あの もう壊れ-- 壊れます
まあ物質のこの変化っていうのは
この行為の変化 それはもうわかりやすいことでしょうし
そんなものはもうちょっと研究すればどんな馬鹿にもわかりますから
仏教はそこはもう相手にしてないんです
で 問題っていうのは 生命としてみると
そういうところは それは科学者にはなかなか研究もできないとわかることもできないところだから
だからこの生命として心という機能があって
その後行為しているんですね
だからこの石一つ落ちてきたんだということ
それはすごいわかりやすい
なんでこの石落ちたんですかと
そこで同じ場所にいた私が石が落ちたところまで動いたとする
それは違うんですよ それは物理学で説明できません
あるいはボール一つ持ってきて
私はこちらからここら辺まで
私でなくても何か転がっていったとする
それは誰にも説明できます
なぜ転がったかと で 私がここからそこまで歩いていく
それは物理学で説明できません
なぜですか？単純でしょう
単純ですけど 説明できません
木の枝がこうやってもう動いたりする
誰も不思議がらない 説明できますから
じゃあ私も同じくこうやって手を振ったりする
それは科学で説明できません
だからそこら辺に何なのかというと
まあこれは仏教の世界で
私の意志があって 歩いたいという
そこまで行きたいという
それでこの物体を動かしちゃったんですね
手を振りたいという意志があって
それでこの物体を木の枝の振りに合わせて動かしたということなんですね
そちらには物理学は関係なくなっちゃう
物理学では科学では説明できません
だから何でも科学で説明できると言って
大槻教授頑張ってますけど
あの 本当のところは 私がここからここまで歩いたことは科学で説明できないんですよ
それはもう大槻教授の科学の能力の世界だからね
まあまあしょうがないですけど
だからこの見解 正しい意見ないんだから
もう大変なことなんです
例えば誰も驚かないんですよ
もうおかしいと思うんじゃないんですか？例えば私がここから玄関まで行ったところ
科学で説明できないと
本当かなと むしろ疑うかもしれません
分かってないんだから
誰もそれについて科学研究してないんです
やってるのはこの足の動きはどのように動くかとか
筋肉はどのように動くかとか
体のバランスはどのように取れるかという物理学だけなんです
物理学だけだったら なんとか反応を起こして体
物理物体として動かせることは可能なはずなんですよ
例えば歩くロボット作ったらスイッチがあって
そのスイッチ入れたら機械が動いてロボットが歩くってことでしょ
もし体 物理学的にできている構造であるならば
どこか何かいじったら我々はさっさっさと歩くはずなんです
でもそれは無理なんです
時々 ある人の背中をひねったりする
そうするとその人は逃げてそこまで行ったりするということは
これは物理学 科学で説明できますか？その人の背中をこうやってひねったら
その人はそこまで歩くんだよと
できませんよ なぜかというと
2回目にやっちゃったら違うことをやるんだから 2
回目やったら違うことをやるんですよ
だから科学っていうのはこういう法則出すからこういう結果だよという固定した法則でしょうに
こちらでは法則固定してないんだから
同じ人の同じところをひねったら
その度に反応が違うんです
だから私は科学で説明できない世界と
できればそういう知恵を持って大槻耕治にチャレンジしてみてください
パラダイスでも辞表持ってます
だから彼らの頭にそういう思考も
そういう知恵も知識も入ってないんだからね
説得するのはすごい難しいんですよ
このへんところの超能力なんか
もうバカもいいところだから
目を閉じても本を読めるんだとかね
それで教授のところに行ったところで
すぐバレちゃいます もともともインチキでしょうし
科学には何もすることできない世界が堂々とあるんですね
それは心の世界 そこで生命が心で動いているということで
心が自分に必要だから体を作っているんであって
だから体の構造も科学ではわからないんですね
なぜそうなるんですかと
説明はない その代わりにこういう風になりますよっていうところで終わっちゃうんです
例えば遺伝があって 遺伝はこういう風に結果出しましょうと
何でしょうかっていうことはわかりません
この人の遺伝見たら ４５歳でがんになる傾向がありますよと
これからの世界なんですけど
小さい時もあの遺伝の設計図を見て
あ この人はあんたはがんになる遺伝持ってますよ
これ取り除いて遺伝的に改良しましょうっていうことは将来的にできる可能性はあります
でも何でしょうかね そうなるんですかね
それは説明はないんです
科学では それに科学は簡単には神はそういう風に作っているんだと
それで説明したつもりなんです
ですから そこら辺で仏教での心がそうやって作っているんだと
物体構想したのは心だから ４０
歳で死ぬか９０歳で死ぬかということは心が決まってるんです
心は自分持っているエネルギーで体作りますから
あんま弱いエネルギーだったら
まあもう３０歳でもガタガタになって死ぬ可能性はあります
それは遺伝でも説明できませんよ
長生きする遺伝の両親にも短命の子供が生まれるんだからね
短命の両親にも長寿の子供が生まれるし
そこでこの この人間の設計図っていうのは業ですよと
業っていうのは行為ですよと
行為っていうのは不思議なものではなくて
全てのものはことごとく行為のみですよということ
別に物体 物体とか別に存在してるんじゃなくて
単なる行為 行為っていうのは瞬間的で瞬間で消える
一つの行為消えちゃうと
それは次の行為になるだけ
我々包丁で何か切るという行為あるでしょうね
切ると行為が終わると同時に
切られるものが二つに分けていくという行為が同時に生まれてくるんです
一つの行為が終わると終わると間なく隙間なく生まれるということ
生まれてくるんです だから隙間なく間なく一つの行為
別な行為になる 別な行為と前の行為というのはまるっきり別々なものなんです
玉ねぎが二つになったことと
包丁が上下っていうんでしょうかね
前と後ろに動いたことっていうのはまるっきり別でしょうに
でも玉が二つになったことは
因果法則 説明する場合
それは結果であって 包丁が上下に動いたということは原因なんですね
原因は別な行為で 結果は別な行為なんです
そこで二つに割った割られた玉ねぎには元に戻すことはできません
元に戻すっていうことは
元の行為に包丁の動きに戻すことはできません
それは違う仕事を次にするんです
まあそうやって色々使う道具によって行為の変化も
例えば電気っていうのは
我々は光で見る経験する場合もあるし
音楽として経験する場合もあるし
電子レンジだったら料理というふうな感じでも食べているのは同じ電気の電気という行為が変化した
電気食べてくださいって誰も食べられないと思いますけど
食べられますよ簡単に
ご飯食べてる あれ電気で食べてるんだからね
米はご飯までに変化させたのは電気だから
何のことなく食べてるんですよ
まあそうやってこの行為なんですよ
業っていうのは それで心はいつでも機能して行為しているんだと
ですから この我々の青写真が業ですよということを理解できればありがたいっていうことになります
理解できないんです それはもう大変難しくて
理解というのは そういうことかと聞いてわかったようなふりをすることはできるんだけど
理解っていうのは この科学研究して何か発見したのように理解することなんですよ
明確に あ こういうことで
こういうことでこうなりましたよという
この厳密なクリアビジョンなんですよ
それはないでしょうに
例えば車のことだったら
車のこと勉強した 研究した人だったらすぐわかるでしょうに
これでからこうなります
これでこうなります これでこうなりますよという
説明できる 今 中目黒で電車から脱線したところで
ちゃんと説明できる まあこういうことで
こうなって こうなって
こういう風に脱線するんだとかね
別に疑う必要もないし
そういうその通り実験してみれば
その通り起こるということ
そのように明確に心の働きっていうのは理解はしにくい
業も理解しにくい ですから
これは人間には無理ということで
お釈迦様もやっぱり一応本当のことはこういうことですよと
青写真は業ですよと それは
止まるなく変化していきますし
でも人間にはそれはちょっと理解できないんだから置いておいてくださいと
それは知ったよく知ったかのように喋る人々は単なる嘘を言ってるんです
あなたは過去でこういうことをしたんだから
今こうなってるんですって
よく日本の宗教の世界であるでしょうね
不幸になってる人なんかに言ったら
あなたはまあ なんとかの時代でなんとかな人になって
あれは言えないはずなんです
本当のことを言うならば
インチキ 自分の感情ばっかり喋る人だったらね
詐欺師だったら平気で言えるんですけどね
まあですから この証券の一つはこの私の青写真は合であるということを理解すること
そこは理解するというか
まあそれはもうもう それしか他の説明はないんだと
いわゆる納得いける説明はないんだと
神様がと言ったら納得いけないんですよ
だから私はこのさんざんこの批判するのは
その そういうポイントを言いたいんですよ
神様は勝手に信じたい人はもう勝手に信じるのは一向に構いませんし
関係もないし もう勝手にやればいいんだけど
もう死んじゃったら神様は迎えに来て
もう連れて行くんだと
じゃあ勝手に信じればいいんだけど
納得いかないんですね
例えば ほんの人生っていうのはあまりにも短いでしょうに
このあまりに短い人生で
我々は何がなんだかわからないうちに死んでしまっちゃうでしょうに
世の中のことやら 自分の人生のことをさえもわかってないうちに死んじゃうでしょうに
ものすごい勢いで生きていなくちゃいけない
みるみるうちに成長していく
まあ十四 五 六歳になっちゃうと
もう異性にたいせきおみが出てきて
もう仕事をしなくちゃ
早く誰かと もうそこら辺でもう会った人と結婚する
これは失敗やとかね で
何一つうまくいかないんですよ
それで子供が生まれてくるたびに
どうやって育てればいいか全然さっぱりわからない
とにかくしょうがなく
もうすごい勢いでも育ててみたら
これ大失敗とかね 結婚した相手もこれ
でわかるともう遅いでしょう
子育てにたった一つの子の子育て
それはとことん勉強して理解して慣れたところで
自分ももうかなり年なんですよ
もう子供がないんですよ
だから人生ってのはあまりにも早く
あっという間に終わっちゃうんですよ
ということで 何一つ我々はろくにできないんですよ
何やっても何か失敗と
仕事の時点で仕事を失敗しちゃうと
まあ失敗でもって勉強するんだと思っても
自分がまあ今度は失敗しないんだよと分かったところで
もうあなたは一度失敗したんだからクビやとも言われてるんですよ
だからリストラにもされちゃうんですね
そういう人生っていうのは
人間みんな起こっていて
一つも完成できなくて
そんな短い人生で我々の運命を永久的に永遠に決めるんだというのは納得いけますかね
神は信じたかないかということで
永遠な地獄か永遠な天国かって決めてくれるんだと
あれほどアホな判断はあるはずがないんですよ
あっという間に終われる終わってしまう人生でしょうに
自分の人生長いと感じることもえらい錯覚なんですよ
あっという間に日は終わって
もうなんだかわからないうちに終わってしまっちゃいますから
いろんなことにチャレンジしなくちゃいけないんだけど
全然やり方わからない
子供を育てなくちゃいけないんだけど
どうやっても突然現れた子供だから
もう経験も何もない もうできないんですね
若者は会社なんかに仕事に就いちゃっても
どうすればいいかさっぱりわからない
仕事に慣れてくるともうクビなんですよ
あんた年だからと それで一旦家に戻ったらボロボロ老人になってるんだから
それからどうすればいいかもうわからない
その間で死んでしまっちゃう
だから隠居生活に慣れようかなと思っちゃうと
もう時間がなく間に合わない
もう死んじゃいますから
だからえらい勢いで生きてるし
何一つうまくいかないんですよ
だからそこは神様は全部決まっているって言ったらね
まあやっぱり犯罪者はもうしょうがないでしょうにと
[背景音楽]誰でも神様を信じるだけで天国に連れて行くんだとかね
それで一人の人がすごい幸せで
一人の人はもう白血病でもう 10歳で死んじゃうとかね
それはどのように説明するかと
一人の人は障害者で生まれてとかね
例えばベトナムの人々は未だにもう飢きんじばっかしですごい苦労してるでしょうね
その人は何の悪いことをしたんですかね
そうやって関係ないところでも苦労しなくちゃいけないし
それで神様が決めたんだいば
とんでもない話なんですよ
納得いかない とんでもないと言ったってもね
ですから その各人の行為の結果だよと
で 理解した方がいくらか納得いけるんですよ
例えば人がもう脱線した電車に自分も乗っていたんだと
なんで自分だけ不幸やって思うんじゃなくて
まあ自分もわざとそういう電車に乗ったんだからね
なんか怪我する運命ではなかったんでしょうかと
これは電車の管理が悪いんだから
私は関係ないんだという風に言ったっても
それはあまり意味がないんですよ
そちらもそちらでも適切に管理しているんだから
サリンに殺された人々も
まあその時そこに群らちゃったんだから
関係ないことでかわいそうに殺されたということも言いにくいんですよ
一部の人はそこで死んじゃったし
一部の人は病気になって終わった
一部の人は何のことなく
もう だからうまい具合にそこで会わせたということになっちゃうでしょうに
だから自分の阿波写真から見れば
その時間でその電車にその車両に乗るでしょうに
私の場合したって 私は私の考え方でどんな車両に乗るかっていうと
大体ほぼ決まってるんです
毎日変化するということ
今日は 1番目に乗る 今日は 15番目にされる
それはないんです で 普通どちらにしても同じ山手線だから行く駅まで行くでしょうということなんですけど
それでもやっぱり私はこちらに乗るんだということがあるんだから
それで もしその車両の中で何か出来事が起きたら自分も巻き込まれるでしょうに
だから自分に関係ないことに巻き込まれて
もうもう死にましたってなんとかいったっても
どこかで自分の関係もあります
ですから この飛行機 事故っちゃってみんな死ぬ場合でも同じことなんですよ
どんな気の細かいことを言ったっても
例えばスーパーいくつかあったっても
やっぱりなんとなく自分が一つに絞る
そういう風になるんですよ
もしその絞った自分が絞ったっていうのは他のスーパーにも行くんだけど
どう見たっても もうあのスーパーに行く回数が多い可能性ありますね
そのスーパーに誰かが毒入り何か入れといて
それ自分が買ってしまって食べちゃって自分が死ぬなんて
これはやっぱりどこかで自分の関係もあります
ですから 物事 自分の心の意思で生きてるんだと
一方の足を踏むのは自分の心だと思ったら
まあ自分には他の選択はないってことなんです
他の選択なくそれを決めたことになっちゃうんです
そこは業ということなんですね
なぜかというと 因果法則で考えれば
原因によって次の結果が起こるんだから
心は次の反応を起こしたっていうことは
前の原因で必然的に起こる結果なんですね
その中で設計図と同じ
建築の場合は設計図と同じ
頼んだ人を頼んだ人 クライアントにも自分が好きな色
好きな窓の枚数 玄関の形とか
いろんな自由な世界ありますよ
自分が家作ってもらうんだったら
でも勝手に 10階の建物をマイホーム 10階にしましょうって言ったっても
それはできません たとえお金あったっても
なぜかというと その地方の決まりもあって
で そういうところにも決まりなければいいんだけど
時々決まりありますよ
何階にするかとかね でも公の方で建物の基準決まっちゃって
色はこの色だよ 東京でもいろんなところありますね
勝手に自分の家で色を塗ってはいけません
色決まってるんです だから区役所に行って
それを調べて 色はいくつかリストがあります
あんたこの色の中で一つ選んでくださいっていうことになっちゃうんです
自分勝手に私は赤にする
青にする 黄色い色にするということもできない場合もありますし
やっぱりその中でもその決まってる色の中で一つ選ばなくちゃいけない
そうやって管理の中でもいくらかの選択の自由があります
その選択の自由により
自分の次の心の回転が決まりますから
だから業っていうのは不思議なもので
過去の業はどうしようもないんだけど
過去の業は次のことに行動しようとすると
いくらか我々に自由があるんです
建物を造るんだったら
建築が基本的な技術的に基本的なことは決まる
それはもう絶対的で変化できませんだけど
建築設計書く人がお客さんに聞くんです
それでもどんなふうな
どのような建物が欲しいですかと
どんな機能が欲しいんですかと
そこでどちらのも完全たる自由は機能してないんです
建築家の完全たる自由も効いてないんだけど
作ってもらう人の完全たる自由も効いてないんです
いくらかな自由があるんです
どちらにしても そこで物事
そういうことで変化していくんです
だから一部だけ見るなかれと
だからこの神のようなこの絶対原因出す人々は
この一部しか見てないんで
変化できないこの自由がない部分しか見てないんです
見てないんだから説明は間違いなんです
我々に自由がない部分もいくらでもありますでしょ
例えば来週までのご飯は今日食べておきますよと
できますかね 来週まで明日からすごく忙しいんだから
料理作ったり買ったりすると時間のロスだから
じゃあ今日はもう 1週間分は今日食べておきますよと
できませんでしょ 自由は利きません
だからって必ずしも 3食食べなきゃ死ぬっていうことではないんです
それで 3食はどのように食べるかと
昼は抜いて夜にするかという自由はあるんです
だからって 1週間分はいっぺんに食べておくという自由はないんですね
だからそこら辺を理解してほしいということで
仏教ではこれ全部まとめて業ということで理解して欲しがっちゃうんですね
だから少々考えて これまあ理解できませんよ
納得いける説明は成り立つんです
業について あ 納得いきますと
神様が決めたんだと言ったって納得いかない
自然だと言ったっても納得いかない
反論いくらでもできます
でも業で説明しちゃうと反論できないんです
でも業に反論する人々はいますけど
その人々が勉強している業論は間違ってるんです
業論正しく語る人はなかなかいないんだから
好き勝手に この証拠ないんだから
好き勝手に説明してるんだから
だから問題なんです 業論正しく説明してもらっちゃうと
あの 完璧に科学的に理解は無理
できません それはもうどうしても
できませんだけど 一応納得いける説明はあるはずなんです
そこまで それぐらい難しく考えてくださいと
それでもお釈迦様は言って
おっしゃってないんですよ
まあ人間の能力のレベル知ってますから
やっぱり優しく言わなくちゃいけないということで
まあとりあえず悪いことをするなかれと
いいことをしなさいと
それで終わってるんです
それ以上考える必要はないんだと
それであんたは安全だと
とりあえず悪いことは全てやめなさいと
悪いことというならば
かすかな悪いことでもやめなさいよと
いいことというならば
全部頑張ってやってみなさいと
だから この初仏教でね
サブパパサカラナクサラサプサプサンパダ
掌握をしないことと善を行うことと
簡単に業論を語ってます
すごいわかりやすく 頭痛くなるまで考える必要はないんです
すごい単純で生きていられる
あ とりあえず私は悪いことしませんと
それは何でしょうか 何でしょうかと言うのは
簡単に答えられる 何か悪いことをしなくちゃいけないという必要は
必然性ありますかと 相手に聞けば
私はどうしても嘘を言わなくちゃいけないんですかね？私はどうしても人を殺さなくちゃいけないんですかね？というふうに聞けば
とにかくやりなさいというのは
どんな世界でもいいことなんですよ
人殺せという人も 人殺すことをいいことだからやりなさいと言ってるんです
だから理屈は あの 仏教の論理はもう潰れません
あの いろんなことに人を殺す
殺されるというか 殺しあるでしょ
行って殺せと もう大使館を爆破しなさいと
大使館は爆破するのはとんでもないことでしょうに
そこで大使館には近寄れない
だったら車いっぱい爆弾かけて
あんた暴走して大使館の中に入り込んでくださいと
いくら警備員止まると
止まるとこ止まる人いて何でもないんだと
行ったら爆破はできませんだから
ただ 行く本人も死にますけど
やりなさいという その場合は
これ悪いことだからやりなさいと言ってないんですよ
いいことだからやりなさいと
我々の宗教のために 神様はアメリカ人が侮辱しているんだから
これ殺すことはあんた神様の
あんた神様はあなたのことをすごく可愛いと思っちゃいますよと
だからやりなさいと言っても爆破するとかです
それは我々に流行っている情報から言うんだけど
本当の状況は私にわかりません
例えば イスラムの過激派がアメリカのなんとか建物爆破したんだとか言ってるでしょうね
この人は犯人やと言ってるんですけど
それは事実かどうか私は信じてないんですけどね
なぜならば アメリカの軍隊にもペントゴンの連中にも自分で爆弾仕掛けて
これはあの人がものすごい遠い国の隠れているなんとか人がやったんだということは
いとも簡単に言えるんだから
だから私は誰が言うことも信じない方が真理だと
なぜならば人は真理語れないんだと
人間には真理語れるはずもないんだと
損人値という感情で物事を見ているんだから
それは一つの真理ではありません
たとえ分厚い証拠やらいろんなことを持っていたっても
それは真理にはなりません
時々この国民のみんなの考え方やと言って
みんな署名して出す場やるでしょ
20万人も署名しているんだから
これぐらい厚い資料出したりする
それでみんなの意見ですかね
あれは そうじゃないんですよ
そうやって街頭で宣伝して運動やるんですよ
みんなどうぞどうぞこれにサインしてください
サインしてください みんなただサインするんですよ
もし確実にこういうことはあってはならないと思うならば
各家で各人が自分で手紙を書いて出さなくちゃいけないんですよ
私はこの建設には反対やと
で 隣の人も隣の人も そうやってみんな自分で直筆で
自分の気持ちで自分の意見書いて出して
そこで 20万人の手紙揃っちゃったら
これはもう人々の意見であるぐらいのことは言えるんです
でも 世の中でそういうことはなかなか成り立たないんですよ
みんなそこまで人のことを考えるんじゃないんです
だから誰かがもう力強い人がまとめるんです
そうすると はいはい わかりました
サインしますということになっちゃうんです
親戚だからとかね いろんなことで
あるいはこのサインをお願いして街頭運動やっていたのは
みんな若い女の子でしたから
高校生でしたからとかね
だからあの真理っていうのは世の中で通りません
ないんです まあ一応今説明したのは殺人とかそういうケースだった
例えばそうやって人殺させる場合にしても
なぜ殺させますか それはいいことだからやってくださいという論理なんですよ
だからいいことをやるんだということっていうのは
世の中の普遍的な決まり
それは悪人にさえ否定できません
おかしいことに 悪人さえも悪行をやってるのは悪行はいいことだからなんです
悪の立場から見て そういうわけだから
難しい言論は理解できませんだから
お釈迦様はいかにすごいかというと
まあすべての悪いことをやめなさい
すべてのいいことをとことんやってくださいという
その一行に一行なんですけど
一行に業をまとめてます
それぐらい本当にそれは真理だと
これはやっぱり反論できないことだとわかって実行する人間になることは
正見の 第1ステージなんですね
だからそれはカンマスカタサマーディッティと言うんですね
私のもの 私の青写真は業であるということ
で 次に次のサマーディッティ
正しい正見というのは何なのかと
例えばこの前の例えに戻りますけど
この汚れた水を飲んだらお腹を壊しますよということも正しいでしょ
間違ってないんだから
完全たる事実ではないんだけど
汚れた水を飲んだだけでお腹を壊すわけでもないんですよ
だったらスープなんかを飲めないはずなんですよ
いろんなもの入ってるんだから
きれいな水と比べると
ただ単にたまたま泥水飲んだんだからって何のことないんですよ
土は別に体はもう消化はしませんだけど
それで水だったら取っちゃうし
溶けないものは体から出しますから問題はないんだけど
それでも一般的に汚れた水を飲んだらお腹が壊せませんということは事実であって
ですから正見なんですよ
でもそんな正見知ったっても何の役にも立ちません
また 単純でね 自分たちの経験でそれぐらいのことを分かればいいでしょうに
何食べればいいかとかね
布団はどんなものにするかとかね
自分で決めればいい そんな難しいことじゃないでしょうに
布団の中身はなんだかなんだとかって決めたって
ただ寝るだけのことでしょうに
ですから それでもって立派な人間になるっていうことは絶対ありえないし
自分がどこの産地の野菜食べるかとか
まあ適当に自分の好みでもう決めればいいんです
それはもうどこか特別な産地で育てると
玉ねぎと特別な産地の卵と特別な産地のキャベツと食べてるんだからといって
他の人間と何が違いますかというと
何も違いはないんですからね
でもそれは正見かもしれませんよ
ある特別な場所で作っているキャベツは
他のキャベツよりはおいしくて
すごくいいものですよということは言えますよ
比べてみれば このキャベツはいいキャベツですよと言えるんですけど
ですから 間違ってるんだっていうことではなくて
大した真理ではありませんと
それで人間がもし成長したければ
もし解脱したければ もし涅槃を体験したければ
絶対的な真理 全てのものに当てはめる
もう最終的に出会う真理を知らなくちゃいけない
他のものは全部一時的な真理なだけなんです
それは一切がドゥッカであることなんです
それは堂々たる真理だから
とても簡単に発見できるでしょうし
我々のこの邪見という
この感情で物事を見るというね
真理知りたくないという
この怠け癖をちょっと取っ払って
ちょっと見れば ああ やっぱりドゥッカですよということは分かりますから
だから一応ドゥッカのことを言ったんだから
ドゥッカの原因もやっぱり渇愛でドゥッカが生まれるんだと
渇愛さえなければドゥッカが生まれないだろうと
もうちゃんと頭が良くなったら
これ分かるだろうという姿勢体を正見の中に入れてるんですよ
だからなんかこのシステムがおかしいんですよ
苦集滅道説明していて
どう説明すると またその道の中にまた道が入っちゃいますからね
まあそれはちょっと避けられないんですよ
この言葉の使い方によって
ですからそこは四聖諦
要するにお釈迦様が使ってるんだから
まあこれはどうにもならないことなの
私の判断で 何でどうにもならない
正見っていうのは苦集滅道を理解することやとおっしゃってるんだから
どうにもならない でも他の正見もありますけど
役に立たない 泥水 汚れた水を飲んではいけないということも正見なんですけど
もうよほどの役に立ちません
心は解脱できるのは 心は成長するのは苦集滅道を理解した時のみ
ですから苦集滅道を理解してください
それを理解することは正見であると
で 苦と集だけ入れたってもいいと思いますけど
私は勝手に 西洋的な学問的に分析して
これダブるんだから ダブると分析じゃないんだと
カテゴリー再生し カテゴライゼーションではないんだと西洋の連中が言ってるんだから
その目で見ればそうなんですよ
ダブってぐるぐる回っちゃいますよ
そこでまたさらに私は正見説明しようとしちゃうと
この場合で どう説明するとまた正見に出会うでしょうに
またそれ説明してようと思ったら
また道に出会うでしょうに
これ延々と続いちゃいますからね
ですから一旦切って捨てた方がいいんですけど
滅と道は でもまた考え
じゃあ滅知らなくてもいいんですかと
やっぱりそうじゃないでしょ
滅も人は知るべきことでしょうに
じゃあ道知らなくてもいいんですかと
いえ 道も知るべきでしょ
だから切り捨てることはできないんです
たとえぐるぐるぐるぐる無限大に回したって
知るべきものは何なのかというと
苦集滅道なんです もし切ってよければ
お釈迦様は切っちゃうんですよ
でも単純に考えれば 正しく知るべきものは苦と集だけですよ
じゃあ滅知る必要ないんだということになっちゃうんですね
例えばある人が滅っていうことはちゃんと体験して
それは正見に入りませんよって言ったらおかしいでしょ
入りますからね 道は知りませんと
修行の方法を知りませんと
と言ったら正見があるわけないでしょうに
そういうことだから 苦集滅道全部入ってるんです
要するにお釈迦様には勝てませんということなんです
いくら西洋的なカテゴライゼーションの方法を持ってきたっても
これはおかしいんだと
インド人の変な考え方やと
もうまとめてないんだと
大雑把すぎやと言っても
勝てません こちらは厳密すぎなんです
お釈迦様の方は 大雑把すぎじゃなくて
悟るまでは堂々巡りということ
悟るまでは堂々巡りをしてなさいという
そういう理解もできませんか
悟るまではエンドです
で 悟ればそれが切れる
悟るまで堂々巡りだったら
ずっと永久的に堂々巡りでしょ
ということじゃないんです
何故そうおっしゃるんですか
ですから このずっとあれですね
ずっと続きますね 回転してますね
回転しませんよ  いえ えーと
苦集滅  こういうことなんですよ
苦集滅道を知る 正見を知る
分かりました やっぱり八正道で物事を見ようとしないとドッカが発見できないんですよ
だから自分がどれぐらい八正道に
八正道をたどっているかという
そこそこ分空に出会う可能性
可能性あります さらに八正道をたどると
さらに空に出会う 八正道は完全になったところで完全に空に出会っちゃう
それで終わっちゃうんですよ
だからわかるまではそれを続けなさいと
そう それは堂々巡りではないんですよ
より明確にわかること
例えば算数っていうのは小学生 1年生の勉強しますけど
これ堂々巡りじゃないんですよ
大学に入っても算数はやる場合あるでしょうに
堂々巡りじゃなくて より明確に
より詳しく よりリアルに理解していくということなんです
でも 勉強の方法は小学生であろうが大学であろうが同じなんですよ
方法間違ったらダメですからね
ですから 八正道っていうのは方法で理解するのはドッカ
ドッカを理解する 最初は小学生のレベルだから
まあほんのちょっとしか理解できませんね
小学生にとってそれは精一杯だから
それでうまくわかったなと思ったら
じゃあ中学で頑張ってくださいと
精一杯なんですよ じゃあ真面目にできたら
ああそうですか と それで終わりじゃなくて
じゃあ高校で頑張ってくださいってなっちゃうんです
それまた精一杯頑張ったところで
だったら大学で頑張ってください
それ終わっちゃったら
だったら大学院でさらに研究して頑張ってくださいというふうに
どんどんレベル高くなっていくんですね
だからこの場合は正見だけに絞るんです
真理する道は何ですかと
まず真理じゃなくて ドッカニローダ
苦しみをなくす方法って何なのかと
まず正見だよ 頭きれいにしなさいよってぐらいのことで
頭きれいにして何か知るでしょう
でもあなたはドッカ知るまでは正見ではありませんと
だからすごい激しくわかりやすい例を出してもそういうわけなんですよ
汚れた水飲んだらお腹壊しますよということは真理ですよ
でも正見ではありません
ドッカを知るまで正見ではありませんと
でもっと頑張ってみてくださいということで
とにかくこの世の中の科学的な事実を発見したっても悟りには至れません
地球の重さが測っ-- 重さを測ってみて知ってるんだと言っても
それは悟りには関係ない
太陽と地球の距離は厳密に測ってるんだよと
月と地球の距離はもう毎日毎日測ってるんだよと
これはセンチ単位で正確に知ってるんだと
別にだから何の役にも立ちませんでしょうに
知ったっても知らなくたっても
宇宙のいろんな星の位置やら名前とかね
名前勝手につけてるんだけどね
そんなものを知ったっても
別に正見でもなんでもないんだよ
そんなものは なぜかというと
別に心の清らかになる方向・ものには何の役にも立ちませんだからなんです
ですから 苦集滅道を知ることにチャレンジしなくちゃいけないということは正見なんです
私はちょっと説明したかったのは
これ なんでこのぐるぐるダブりますか？というぐらいのことなんですけどね
それはもう避けられないんですよ
知るべきものは４つもありますから
で その代わりお釈迦様は一応二つに分ける時もあります
ドッカとドッカサムデ
苦と苦の原因 それ二つだけわかればいいやということを言っているところはあります
まあこれ因果法則の言い方で
この原因と結果というということで
だからこの二つに分けちゃうと
四聖諦をね 二つ二つに分けちゃうと
原因結果 原因結果なんです
でも二番目の場合は結果と結果の原因なんんですけど
それをなぜ順番変わって
例えばドッカは原因じゃないね
ドッカは結果でサムデは原因なんですね
結果言って原因言う ね
知ろうとは結果で 道は原因なんですね
だから結果行って原因言うという
結果から原因に行くという
これはあの まあそういうことで成り立っています
まあサマーディティで今日終わり
もう私はサマーディティもう五分以内で説明して終わろうかなと計算していたんだけど
今日でこの経典終わりにしましょうと思ったんだけど
放送局ではないんだからもうフルフルと言っちゃったんです
[笑い]放送局の場合はちゃんと時間
あ あと五分しかないかという話をしてます
[笑い]あっという間に終わりました
さあ でも正見というのは大変なことだとぐらいは理解してほしいんですよ
こんなもう もう大変なことだと
とてつもないことだと
世の中で誰にもないことだと
それぐらいすごく自由になりますよ
あれ知らなくちゃ これ知らなくちゃ
この本読まなくちゃ これって
もう別にどちらでも嘘だからね
知ったって 知らなくたってまあどうってこともないってことになりますからね
その場合 知るべきことは簡単に絞られます
自分の仕事に必要なものだけに知識絞ればいいんです
他のものは知らないままがいいんですよ
仕事に必要なものとするものも別に事実ではありませんだからね
だから人間には真理知りたいという口先の言葉だけあるんだけど
本当は知りたくないんです
ですから 母親は子供のことを知らない
子供は母親のことを知らない
母親に助けられ育てられているのにも関わらず
子供は自分のことは母親に言わない
真理は成り立ってないんです
ですから みんな一人一人なんです
ものすごい孤独なんです
先生 それはわかってない
徹底した孤独なんです
で それまではいいんだけど
我々の心が 私たちは私たちを騙してるんです
悟らないのはそこなんです
母親騙すのはわかりますけど
大体自分にぐらい正直になってみればどうですかと
自分にも正直じゃないんです
その瞑想でチャレンジしてみるのはそのこと
だけど本当は真理はすごく簡単ですよ
発見してみれば すごい簡単なんですけど
なんで発見しないかというと
自分が自分に嘘ついてるんです
自分の頭にもずっと嘘の情報とことんとことん流してるんです
例えば高慢っていうのは嘘なんですよ
私は立派な人だとかね
よく頑張ってるんだとかね
色々自分に暗示かけてるでしょ
全部嘘の情報なんです
瞑想しながらも嘘の情報はずっとインプットしちゃうんです
その癖なんですね 問題は
それ直っちゃうと もうすぐ即座に見つかるんです
真理は じゃあ ここら辺で終了します
[終礼]